my name is welcome to Candace I'm
wearing a waist tight shirt and schemas
I've known about this game like forever
seriously that that's a nice torch and I
torch
you look like one of those things you
clean your ears with I mean but what I
Jennifer add so yeah
zebras seem to like this baby it's
actually kind of creepy Wow someone out
there what what are you doing shut up
shut your mouth lady girl I think it's
fun to laugh hahaha yeah it's fun hey
they're more of them
alright my climbing it oh oh it's the
ocean this Hill is a awful what I buy
stop looking down kids all right
oh that's a house that only I could get
up somehow why would anyone put a house
there it's a terrible place to put a
house stop okay I got a jump I got a
jump to get to this is not look friendly
alright let's go inside Wow while you
bein away y'all butts so tiny
that's your basement generator had run
out of fuel it's my house in the middle
of nursery sorry Alice your house has
been overrun with dark loving night ends
the [ __ ] that's scour these parts of the
coastline as you know they're usually
little facing what they can find in the
forest but they are extremely tight
always I'm afraid I won't give up a new
foundation well never go through each
fighting candles I gotta fight candles
to scare limps away and finally make
your way to the basement to refuel the
generator with a electricity
man same soul surely all right
I'm a how do I lick them doesn't worry
what dude
Wow night games no no no no no no no wow
I don't think I need to see it's my
bedroom
why are you nice abs whoa what check
what are you doing sorry dr. pips
all right I'm an that is MIDI it all
right that looks like I have a mangina
almost a dog's like oh my god is so
awesome I got a stat I damn [ __ ] yeah
mice I'm like a man I'm a little metal
there I got that from licking no don't
say oh well this is bright and nice
let's see what we got in the kitchen
lasagna maybe Baba
what are you doing why did he do that
Chewbacca what shut doctor
what's going on
what's going on why is it black what
happened I got to redo everything son of
a [ __ ]
fine doodoo oh okay we can be friends we
can be friends we can be friends
don't kill me how you like that it's
pretty cozy would you like some
marmalade no are you looking for
something
oh that painting over there oh that is
just what what why did he go but it
[ __ ] need to go that is awesome
holy [ __ ] what is going on you guys are
sick okay dude
hello doo doo doo doo doo that's me
again
[ __ ] I lost them we got to find the key
breasts don't worry I got a plan the
plan is to charge everything [ __ ] that
was my skype what are you doing in my
bedroom
you should not be alive right now don't
kill it don't kill me what happened
stops totally ruin it all right don't
worry Bryce I got a plan
platypus okay fine plan the plan is the
following we get this key ah that it is
now I can get into my cellar all right
good
hello oh [ __ ] it's dark now
oh dude what happened what happened I
don't even know I bet it was Chewbacca
[ __ ] damn it damn that guy's this stair
I'm Scott actually I we hold me hold me
in the loading screen what did I do
all right we got to redo everything
fantastic I loved redoing [ __ ]
don't worry breasts I got a special what
are you doing you say hard to the like
oh I'll it what the hell i freakin
littered at it that's not how you say it
is it lighten in it i lighten in it
sounds really good when you say lighten
it like today huh I'll lighten the net
like light in the day what say what
Peter what did you do I lightened it it
I liked it at it huh huh huh okay I'm
sorry too random right now shut up
that's right that's right have you seen
this Chet ate it
that's right you ate it good thing you
don't eat you don't eat candles I try
that once when I was really drunk don't
tell anyone okay come here come here
stupid [ __ ] stupid [ __ ]
he doesn't know what he's doing I know
what I'm doing and that is taking the
key ah yes now I can get into my cell oh
boy yeah yeah
now wait wait wait Lee all right why is
it dark here now don't you don't you
dare do that again all right come on
step it [ __ ]
the sellers gotta be I just can't get
over this Pam thumbnail right there all
right
[ __ ] don't worry bro I got this I got
this
come here why don't you have a penis oh
that's right you're a woman come here
come here come here
that's right fell right in my trap
that book is awesome I want to lick it
all right let's go to the cellar oh
let's not go to the tower
I guess I have to all right guys I got
this don't worry don't worry
I [ __ ]
I'll be gentle bow what I add don't kill
me
don't go that no gal they don't give me
no kami don't give an age yeah that's
right lightning reaction anyone else
want it with me I didn't think so
Oh another one don't kill me please
shut up okay here's the generator let me
just touch you and it what huh huh I
barely touched it what don't don't break
don't break keep doing what you're doing
no don't break is it working I'm not
sure I'm gonna swing that thing a little
more huh how didn't you do that
that's how you do it swing it what do
you want from me
I only want the light is it working
it's not bright enough generate ha ha ha
let there be light
pig said bah and the barrels came [ __ ]
ok let's just head back home to my home
- back home and baby not a glory that's
all
are they Layton I think they are like in
a minute probably the correct grammar
all right I guess what do we do now is
we just [ __ ] go to sleep finally I
can get some sleep
I wasn't spelled right but that's ok all
right
we're dead at breath let's run away I
can't click it that's ironic all right
hope you enjoyed that's a fun little
game I'll leave it download link in
description if you want to play it
subscribe to come a bridge today and
I'll see you next episode oh boy oh boy
[Music]
hope that wasn't apparent or anything
they're fine don't worry kids
thank you talking to myself Rosaleen hey
why were you lucky Neil well excuse me
for her are you kidding that oh it's a
squirrel I thought it was a teddy bear
coming out of nowhere
you ran over it anyway